okay so this video is going to be an
overview of cellular respiration if
you're looking for a more detailed
explanation of the process if you read
below in the description box there will
be a link to a more detailed video that
I've already created so let's go ahead
and discuss an overview of cellular
respiration
okay so cellular respiration you know
what is it well ultimately it's a
cellular process that ends up producing
this molecule right here adenosine
triphosphate abbreviated ATP this is a
molecule that that provides you cells
with the energy that they need to do
work so understanding how cells make
their energy is actually a really
important concept in biology one thing
to mention of cellular respiration is
that it's an exothermic chemical
reaction it's one that releases energy
and if we look at the formula for
cellular respiration molecule of glucose
c6h12o6 plus oxygen will yield six
molecules of water some carbon dioxide
and energy because energy is in the to
the left of the air are the reactants
and the right of the rear of the air are
the products because energy is listed as
a product energy has been released in
this chemical reaction hence a
exothermic reaction and for the record
with the energy that we are referring to
our molecules of ATP ATP is the energy
that is released during cellular
respiration so let's go into this in a
little more detail okay so who performs
cellular respiration well that would be
all eukaryotic cells because eukaryotic
cells possess mitochondria and so for
eukaryotic organisms we're talking about
members of kingdom Protista like this
amoeba right here we're talking members
of kingdom fungi like this mushroom
members of kingdom Plantae the plants
and members of kingdom Animalia the
animals so organisms a eukaryotic
perform cellular respiration
and so where does cellular respiration
occur well we know it occurs in
eukaryotic cells but more specifically
within the mitochondria mostly within
the mitochondria of eukaryotic cells and
so what happens during cellular
respiration well food molecules such as
glucose are used to create ATP so here
we have a young lady eating a meal and
if we zoom on into her bloodstream after
we eat a meal the G stands for glucose
after we eat a meal glucose is absorbed
into our bloodstream so after a meal we
have a high concentration of glucose
within our bloodstream and through
simple diffusion you can see there's a
low concentration of glucose in the two
cells to the left of the of the vein so
glucose will diffuse into the cells
particularly then into the mitochondria
and the mitochondria will start to
produce a large amount of ATP and we're
going to get into this process of how
the mitochondria produces a large amount
of ATP as we continue through the rest
of this video
okay you know it's worth mentioning that
you know for every single molecule of
glucose you know here's one molecule of
glucose c6h12o6 glucose the through
cellular respiration 36 molecules of ATP
can be produced that's a pretty good
investment you know if you can turn one
molecule of glucose into 36 molecules of
ATP well it's even more when we look at
triglycerides you know here's of here's
a lipid with three fatty acids attached
to it that's why it's a triglyceride
here and triglycerides a single
triglyceride can produce up to 146 ATP's
and this is generally where we get ATP
from from carbohydrates such as glucose
and from our the lipids that we consume
the triglycerides that we consume in our
diet
well you know let's actually get into an
overview now of cellular respiration we
can kind of divide it into three stages
stage one step one glycolysis and this
is really defined as the breakdown of
glucose so here we have us have a couple
cells let's have a molecule of G for
glucose diffuse into the cell
notice how the glucose is in the
cytoplasm of the cell the mitochondria
is really important but not until the
later steps so glycolysis occurs in the
cytoplasm of cells what we're gonna do
is we're gonna zoom on into that top
cell and when we zoom into the top cell
we can see the molecule of glucose even
though there the entire formula is
c6h12o6 notice for simplicity I've only
drawn the six carbons arranged in a
hexagon in reality there's 12 hydrogens
and six oxygens but just for simplicity
I've only drawn the the ring there of
the six carbons that glucose is going to
get broken down during glycolysis and so
what happens is there are enzymes in the
cytoplasm of our cells that will break
down this particular glucose here and so
if you've seen my other videos you
probably know I'd like to animate a pair
of scissors as symbolic of glucose
excuse me as symbolic of enzymes because
enzymes tend to break down molecules and
so that's why I've chosen and a pair of
animated scissors here to represent
enzymes and so as the glucose is broken
down by the enzymes the glucose has been
broken into a couple fragments that are
now called pyruvate so you have two
pyruvates pyruvate one on the left
pyruvate two on the left on the right
notice in the breakdown of glucose two
molecules of ATP are created and so what
happens next is those pyruvates those
broken fragments of glucose we're not
done breaking those down those two
pyruvates will migrate into the
mitochondria
and when they enter into the
mitochondria we're gonna move on into
step two now of cellular respiration so
when we move on into stage two of the
krebs cycle if we zoom I'm into that
mitochondria we can see that there's a
inner layer in the darker color this
inner layer by the way goes by the name
of the matrix and in this darker inner
layer we can see the two pieces of the
pyruvates the what was once glucose
which has been broken apart and so where
does the krebs cycle occur it's in this
inner mitochondrial layer here again
called the matrix and there's the two
pyruvates
and so when we focus on what happens
next
well those pyruvates which at one time
we're glucose those pyruvate are gonna
be broken down even further and in order
to do that of course we have to use
enzymes so in my animation I've added my
animated scissors which are symbolic of
enzymes and what these enzymes are gonna
do are break down the pyruvates even
further and when they do molecules of
ATP some molecules of carbon dioxide and
hydrogen ions are going to be created
now in reality the krebs cycle is a
pretty complex series of one reaction
after another after another after
another after another after another in
this simplified overview I'm really just
showing the main things that are created
so when I click the mouse again a lot of
things are gonna happen three-two-one a
lot is happening right now
carbon dioxide is being created co2 two
molecules of ATP are created and some
hydrogen ions have moved into the outer
membrane the outer layer of the
mitochondria the lighter orange or color
of the mitochondria again in reality the
krebs cycle is a pretty complex series
of events I'm just breaking it down to
its simplicity right here well notice
again how all the hydrogen's have
accumulated in the
in the outer layer of the mitochondria
and all that carbon dioxide is then
released and that's partly what we
exhale every time we inhale oxygen and
exhale carbon dioxide from from cellular
respiration but notice again two
molecules of ATP have been created well
in stage one in glycolysis we also
created two molecules of ATP so stage
one produced to stage two produced two
so so far we're up to four well from the
beginning of the video we said 36
molecules of ATP are created so the
greatest amount must come next and the
final stage is the electron transport
chain and this is where we see the
greatest amount of ATP produced and this
happens in the fluid within that orange
layer of the mitochondria and so what
happens is the mitochondria is as
aerobic which means the mitochondria
takes an oxygen so this stage of
cellular respiration requires Oh to
oxygen from the atmosphere and again
representing enzymes will be animated
scissors and so there's some animated
scissors right there symbolic of enzymes
and what the enzymes do they bring
together hydrogen oxygen adp and a
phosphate they bring all these together
and again this is an overview so I'm
highly highly simplifying the real
electron transport chain but if I just
add a phosphate and an ADP in the
electron transport chain the enzymes
bringing together the adp the phosphate
the oxygen in the hydrogen and through a
pretty complex series of events ATP gets
created now this happens multiple times
so let me add another adp and phosphate
and again the enzymes will help to bring
together the adp the phosphate oxygens
and hydrogen's and create ATP and let's
do that one more time so let's add
another adp and another phosphate and
the enzymes help bring together oxygen
and hydrogen and ADP and P
and through a pretty complex chemical
reaction ATP gets created and in reality
this happens again thirty-two times
total so when you add up the ATP from
glycolysis which was - plus the ATP from
the Krebs cycle which was - plus the ATP
from the electron transport chain which
is 32 that single molecule of glucose
that we began with has been used to
produce 36 molecules of ATP and so when
we wrap up this video here we can see
our mitochondria taken in glucose in
releasing a whole bunch of ATP this ATP
is then used by cells in order for them
to do their work so if you're in my
class maybe pause the video try
answering these questions that I'm happy
to check your answers before or after
school one day I hope you found this
overview to be helpful if you'd like to
learn some more of the details of
cellular respiration make sure you check
out the description box below the video
thank you